now if you're wondering what's going on
in the most vile identifying marital
dispute of all time johnny depp versus
amber heard i was going to do a whole
segment on this but i saw this headline
and got to be honest i lost the stomach
for it
it wasn't me it was the dog amber heard
denied in court today that she defecated
in their marital bed and instead blamed
depp's yorkshire terrier
wow the star in at vogue a tiny 150 year
old pub based in the village of vogue in
rural cornwall landlords mark and rachel
graham got a threatening letter from
vogue magazine publishers conde nast
warning them the confused customers
might think it's all part of the fashion
giant conde nast told them as far as the
general public is concerned a connection
between your business and ours is likely
to be inferred please would you like to
let us know whether you will change your
company's name how dumb does vogue think
the pub customers are exactly
welcome they now thankfully eventually
came to his senses and back down but
husband and wife landlord team mark and
rachel graham said they may now start a
local parish newsletter and call it
vogue magazine i've got to say when i
first heard about this i thought it was
a joke a windup that vogue this
wonderful global magazine fashion empire
would be threatened by a little pub what
was your reaction oh good evening pierce
yeah mine was exactly the same as you i
opted the letter and i thought it was
one of the customers
having a joke having a bit of a laugh
until i
did some research looked into it and
found out no they were serious they
really did think a little village pub in
cornwall is going to be confused with a
fashion magazine and rachel i mean it's
obviously very flattering if they think
that you're you know an offshoot
of this wonderful fashion
uh
iconic empire were you personally
flattered do you think they'd seen you
in some dazzling dresses or something no
i wouldn't have thought so now
has it been a good talking point for the
locals uh mark because obviously
everyone's been having a good laugh i
think reading about it but to actually
live there and go in the pub must have
been hilarious the last few days
well it's it's a bit mixed actually most
people think it's hilarious and and what
they're doing but they're you know
there's a good few people that uh
cornwall is a very proud county very pro
county and they see this there's um
a company like vogue trying to take over
and subjugate the little guy and have a
go at the cornish and it's our name
we've had it for ages you know um
apparently it's in the doomsday book
vogue so there's a few that think um you
know we should actually take vogue to
court and make them change their name
now
well generations of children and the
scouts and girl guides have been honored
with badges for honing their life skills
in orienteering camping navigation yeah
real skills now they have a brand new
challenge
[Music]
yes the new challenge for british girl
guides for which they actually get
badges lording their success is walking
to the chip shop
the new badge features a smiling lady
french fry and hiking boots happily
striding into a chip shop while hungrily
brandishing a fork kids can get another
badge for eating a pizza i'm not joking
all this is the uk is set to become the
fattest country in europe with 37 of the
nation obese by 2030 the official goal
guiding twitter account says it's
absolutely worth teaching and
celebrating adding the recipients of
being honored
for their independence enjoying the
outdoors money management and following
directions following directions really
to a chip shop judging by the fat record
in this country we have no problem
finding chip shops